young dolph has died he was 36.
[Music]
according to multiple reports the rapper
died on wednesday after being shot in
memphis young dolph was survived by his
partner mia jay and their two children
now the music world is sharing tributes
on social media megan the stallion
posted this photo to instagram writing
in the caption quote everybody that
knows me knows that i played this man's
music every day he was so genuine so
real so kind to me and t ferris always
rest in peace to a real legend megan was
featured in young dolph song rnb please
don't come and tell me about no story
that you heard this is not just a
mystery i do not kick it with no burst
llc wrote on twitter rest in power young
brother i pray your children and family
are covered and lifted up by the
almighty and kiki palmer shared a
personal story on instagram recalling
when she met young doll's partner mia
and told her she was a fan of the rapper
next to this photo of young dolph mia
and their two kids kiki wrote when this
happens you don't just take away that
life but you hurt a million other people
they were carrying i'm so sorry for your
last mia and i'm sorry we lost you dolph
young dolph was previously shot in
november 2017 he recovered after being
in critical condition
i'm in control of the dolph doff
determined when doc won't drop dolphins
spent all the money on dolph i can't
think of one person that gave me a
dollar a coin
real name adolf robert thornton jr the
rapper broke into the scene with his
debut album the king of memphis
please come back
young dolph's latest release dropped in
march dumb and dumber too his second
collab with key glock he was also the
cousin of late rapper juice world who
died in 2019
[Music]
you